I had never worn a dress before. I'm sure it was like slightly graceless as like all the things I did at the time seem to have been. I met peers on our very first week in college. It must have been day one or two. It was really early. We went to a super PC liberal arts school and so our freshman mixer was a cross-dressing dance, which is such an outdated term now, but whatever, that's what it was called. I think all they told us was you should wear clothes of the opposite gender. They probably said it in a way that's slightly more, you know, literate in the differences between gender and biological sex than what I just said. It was a strange way to make first impressions
我以前从来没穿过裙子。我确信那动作有点笨拙，就像我当时做的所有事情一样。我在大学的第一周就遇到了同龄人。那一定是一或二天。时间真的很早。我们去了一所超级政治正确的文科学校，所以我们的新生联欢会是一场反串舞会，现在看来这个词已经过时了，但管他呢，当时就是这么叫的。我想他们对我们说的全部就是你应该穿异性的衣服。他们说这话的方式可能比我刚才说的要稍微有一点文化气息，懂得性别与生物学性别之间的差异。这真是一种留下第一印象的奇怪方式。
on each other, not because we were scared of wearing dresses or backwards baseball caps or whatever we wore that night. It was because for many of us, we had to borrow clothes from the other people in our hall. It was weirdly intimate. Pears and I, complete strangers, swapped outfits. You're tall and I'm tall and I think that you're probably the only person in the hall of not the building whose clothes would have fit me.
彼此之间，并不是因为我们害怕穿裙子或反戴棒球馆帽或者我们那天晚上穿的任何衣服。这是因为对我们许多人来说，我们不得不从走廊里的其他人那里借衣服。这种感觉出奇地亲密。皮尔斯和我，完全的陌生人，互换了服装。你很高，我也很高，而且我觉得你可能是大厅里甚至整栋楼里唯一一个衣服适合我的人。
I remember I loaned Pears a pink, swirly patterned mini-dressed from the 60s that I had bought from a thrift store, and I had no idea if he would take care of it or even return it, but Pears tried it on. It looked great. And he went to check himself out in the bathroom down the hall. And here's what happened next. I immediately locked myself out of my room. And I was like, oh no, my keys are in my room, room because I didn't have ever put them. The dress had no pockets. Peers is brand new roommate, let him
我记得我借给皮尔斯一件我在旧货店买的60年代粉色漩涡印花迷你裙，我当时根本不知道他会不会爱惜它，甚至会不会还给我，但皮尔斯试穿了。看起来棒极了。然后他去走廊尽头的卫生间照了照镜子。接下来的事情是这样的。我立刻把自己反锁在房间外面。当时我想，哦不，我的钥匙在房间里，因为我从来没有把它们放……那条裙子没有口袋。皮尔斯崭新的室友让他
back in. But then he went to sleep. So Peers wanted to make sure he didn't make that mistake again. He couldn't lose his keys at the party. We all ended up in the big dance hall where there's really loud music. And it was like unbearably hot. All the ladies eyebrow pencil mustaches were running onto their teeth with sweat and things like that. And I believe I just clutched my keys in my hand and thought about it really hard all night, which sounds crazy. Articles of interest, a show about what we wear.
进去了。但后来他去睡觉了。所以皮尔斯想确保他不会再犯同样的错误。他不能在派对上丢了钥匙。我们最后都来到了那个放着震耳欲聋音乐的大舞厅里。那里热得让人受不了。所有女士用眉笔画的小胡子都在汗水的作用下流到了牙齿上，诸如此类。我相信我当时只是把钥匙紧紧攥在手里，整晚都在拼命想着它，这听起来太疯狂了。服装趣谈，一档关于我们穿什么的节目。
And so maybe the idea is about clothing. You can attach. Our idea is about class. An idea of home to a piece of cloth. These are glass for a market-eo or a kind of... I want it. Any fork and wear clothes, but if you haven't got the attitude and style to carry it off,
所以也许这个想法是关于服装的。你可以附加。我们的想法是关于阶级的。对一块布料的家的概念。这些是……或者某种……我想要。任何人都可以穿衣服，但如果你没有那种能够驾驭它的态度和风格，
man, you're just the clothes boss. Women's wear is littered with fake pockets that don't open or shallow pockets that could hardly hold a paperclip. If there are pockets at all, they are just smaller and they fit less than men's pockets do. And you don't have to take my word for it. Here we are going to the police supply store. I wanted to find an example of a uniform that had pockets and compared those made for men and those for women. This is the shop that provides the uniforms
伙计，你只是衣服的架子。女装里到处都是不开口的假口袋，或者是浅到几乎夹不住一枚回形针的浅口袋。如果有口袋的话，它们也只是更小，装的东西比男人的口袋少。你不用听信我的话。现在我们要去警察用品店。我想找一个有口袋的制服例子，并比较为男性和女性制作的制服。这家店提供
for the Oakland police. And when I asked the store manager if I could look at the men's and women's uniforms, this is what he told me. Are you ready for this? I'm ready for this. The women wear the men's. Really?
奥克兰警局的制服。当我问店长是否可以看看男式和女式的制服时，他是这么对我的。你准备好了吗？我准备好了。女警穿男警的。真的吗？
Because the pockets are too small and women's. Wait, really? That's right? That is why. But there is a women's that they make. But I don't care, well, I've got some over here. But traditionally, they use the mins because the pockets are bigger. And they can put things in them where the women are smaller, which I can show you.
因为女式的口袋太小了。等等，真的吗？没错？这就是原因。但他们确实也做女式的。但我不在乎，好吧，我这儿有一些。但传统上，他们用男式的，因为口袋更大。他们可以在里面装东西，而女式的较小，我可以向你展示。
Yes. And they won't fit. That's fascinating. Now you have something to blog about. I'll give you something to blog about. Man's great evolutionary advantage is the creation of tools. The problem is we're not marsupials. We need to carry them somehow.
是的。而且它们装不下。太迷人了。现在你有些东西可以写博客了。我给你提供点写博客的素材。人类伟大的进化优势是工具的制造。问题是，我们不是有袋动物。我们需要用某种方式携带它们。
And this idea of who has access to the tools they need, who can walk through the world comfortably and securely. This is what we are talking about when we talk about pockets. Pockets speak to this question of preparedness and your ability to move in public and to be confident. It's really difficult to get around if you don't have what you need and it's about, I think, mobility and movement in public. Hana Carlson lectures at the Rhode Island School of Design where she teaches classes in material culture, fashion history, and fashion theory.
而关于谁能获得他们需要的工具、谁能舒适而安全地在这个世界行走的这个想法。这就是我们在谈论口袋时所谈论的内容。口袋体现了这种准备状态以及你在公共场合行动和自信的能力。如果你没有你需要的东西，出行会非常困难，我认为这关乎公共场合的机动性和移动性。哈娜·卡尔森在罗德岛设计学院讲课，在那里她教授物质文化、时尚史和时尚理论课程。
And she is working on a book about pockets. If the formal question for me is, what difference does it make? But, you know, what's the difference between a pocket and a bag? And I think the key difference is that the pocket is internal and its secret. A bag can be stolen. A bag can be lost. And then, that's it. You don't have your things anymore.
她目前正在写一本关于口袋的书。如果对我而言的正式问题是，这有什么区别？但是，你知道，口袋和包有什么区别？我认为关键的区别在于口袋是内在的，而且是秘密的。包可以被偷。包可能会丢。然后，就那样了。你再也没有你的东西了。
With the pocket inside, you don't have to think about it. You forget about it. But you still have stuff in there. It is seen as this territory of your own that connects you to the objects you carry. Those objects become part of you. Case in point, Thomas Jefferson. Jefferson was called a walking calculator for all of the miniature tools and devices he carried. miniature scales, drawing instruments, a thermometer, a surveying compass, a level, a globe, and he was able to jot down his observations
有了里面的口袋，你就不必去想它了。你把它抛在脑后。但你口袋里依然有东西。它被视为你自己的领地，将你与你随身携带的物品连接起来。这些物品成了你的一部分。典型的例子就是托马斯·杰斐逊。杰斐逊被称为行走的计算器，因为他随身携带了各种微型工具和设备：微型天平、绘图仪、温度计、测量罗盘、水平仪、地球仪，他能够把日常漫步中的观察结果
from his daily wanderings. Historically, men have been the ones with these tools for public life on their person at all times. In Hana Carlson's research, she found a lot of accounts of women complaining about this. One woman noted that her son was better equipped than she or her daughter. And she concludes that a boy's pockets are his certificate of empire. All through life, he will carry the scepter of dominion by the right of his pockets. I mean, so this is great language I loved.
随时记录下来。从历史上看，男性一直是随时随地将这些用于公共生活的工具带在身上的人。在哈娜·卡尔森的研究中，她发现了大量女性对此抱怨的记录。一位女性注意到，她的儿子比她或她的女儿装备更齐全。她得出结论：男孩的口袋就是他的帝国证书。在他的一生中，他将凭藉口袋的权利手持统治的权杖。我的意思是，这真是太棒的语言了，我很喜欢。
I mean, it's playful, it's funny, but there's some seriousness here about what later cost him historians call real social handicap. Pockets are just a perfect metaphor for privilege, not only because they are so easily taken for granted by the people who have them, but also because, like the categories of race and gender themselves, pocket disparity is a construct. It's made up. There's no reason for women's pockets to be so small. Back in the 18th century, women's pockets were quite large. You could hold quite a lot of them. There are accounts of women putting food in it to eat later.
我的意思是，它很顽皮，很有趣，但其中也有一些严肃的成分，关于后来被经济历史学家称为真正的社会劣势的东西。口袋简直是特权的完美隐喻，不仅因为拥有它们的人认为它们是理所当然的，还因为，就像种族和性别本身的分类一样，口袋的差异是一个人为构建的概念。它是凭空捏造的。女式口袋没有理由做得这么小。早在18世纪，女式口袋就相当大。你可以装下相当多的东西。有记录显示女性把食物放在里面留着以后吃。
accounts of women putting food in it to eat later. They would have writing tools, maybe a small diary, sewing implements. They could carry quite a lot, especially if you had two. This is Clarissa Escara. Yes, I'm Clarissa Escara. I am the associate curator of costumant textiles at the Los Angeles County Museum of Art. And where are we now?
有记录显示女性把食物放在里面留着以后吃。她们会有书写工具，可能还有一本小日记本，缝纫工具。她们可以携带相当多的东西，特别是如果你有两个的话。这是克丽萨·埃斯卡拉。是的，我是克丽萨·埃斯卡拉。我是洛杉矶县艺术博物馆服装和纺织品部门的副馆长。我们现在在哪里？
We are in a storage area at the museum for our department and so we have everything laid out on a table, currently covered with tissue, but I will reveal them one at a time. It was a little hard to picture on the radio, but indulge me for a second. Pockets used to be a completely separate garment. They were really more like pouches. Pockets being suspended from the waste has a really long history actually. It started for both men and women in the medieval era. They were suspended from their waste over their clothes. And then in some time in the late 17th century, men started having clothes made where pockets were incorporated. They were in their coats, their waste coats, and in their breeches. And women's pockets remained separate
我们在博物馆我们部门的储藏区，所以我们把所有的东西都摆在一张桌子上，目前盖着薄纸，但我会一次揭晓一件。在广播里可能有点难以想象，但请容我讲一会儿。口袋过去是一件完全独立的服装。它们其实更像是小袋子。口袋悬挂在腰部其实有着非常悠久的历史。它在中世纪时期就开始为男女两性所使用了。它们悬挂在衣服外面的腰部。然后在17世纪末的某个时候，男人们开始制作将口袋融入其中的衣服。它们在他们的外套、马甲和马裤里。而女式的口袋仍然与
from the rest of clothing. Oh, kind of like a fatty pack. No, no, no, no. I think, okay, think of the pockets on the inside of your jeans, right? Those tear-dropped, shaped pouches. They were kind of like that, but they were just on their own,
其余的衣服分开。哦，有点像腰包？不，不，不，不。我想，好吧，想想你牛仔裤里面的口袋，对吧？那些泪滴形状的小袋子。它们有点像那样，但它们是独立的，
like separate from pants, and they were attached to a string. And these would be tied around the waist. Yes. And in some cases these patches are really big, like the length of your forearm. And these detachable pockets were then worn under women's dresses. So even though a lot of old dresses look like they have pockets, they really just have cut slits in them.
就像和裤子分开一样，它们系在一根绳子上。这些东西会系在腰间。是的。在某些情况下，这些小袋子真的很大，有你的前臂那么长。这些可拆卸的口袋随后被穿在女性的连衣裙里面。所以即使许多旧连衣裙看起来有口袋，它们其实只是在上面剪了狭缝。
Women had slits made in the petty coats and dresses and they could access their pockets by going through those slits made in the petty coats and dresses, and they could access their pockets by going through those slits. You could reach through your dress to get to your detachable pocket pouches. Does that make sense? Sure, why not? Would you like to see them?
女性在衬裙和连衣裙上开有狭缝，她们可以通过穿过衬裙和连衣裙上的狭缝来拿取口袋里的东西，她们可以通过穿过衬裙和连衣裙上的狭缝来拿取口袋里的东西，从而拿到口袋。你可以把手伸过连衣裙去够你的可拆卸口袋。这讲得通吗？当然，为什么不呢？你想看看它们吗？
Yes. So I thought we would kind of start with a more simpler ones and then kind of go into the more complicated ones because they were really functional, but also they were an opportunity for Splendor. I'm actually just gonna cut to the complicated expensive fancy pockets because they are indeed very splendid. Oh Wow, so these were very very finely embroidered. This one is a silk pocket and it's lightly quilted and then it is covered with this beautiful
是的。所以我想我们应该从比较简单的开始，然后进入比较复杂的那些，因为它们真的很有功能性，但同时它们也是一个展现华丽的机会。我其实要直接跳到那些复杂、昂贵又花哨的口袋，因为它们确实非常华丽。哦，哇，这些刺绣真的是非常非常精致。这是一个丝绸口袋，经过了轻微的绗缝，然后上面覆盖着精美的
floral chain stitch embroidery. So these are all tiny, tiny, little chain stitches. Oh my god. It's really fine, and there's a pair of them at match. And this is something that she just wore. And only she and the woman who helped her get dressed, and perhaps her lover saw. Pockets were almost like lingerie, especially the beautiful expensive ones. The pockets were this intimate thing, close to the body, holding your most precious items
花卉链式刺绣。所以这些全都是微小无比的链式针脚。哦天哪。它真的非常精致，而且是一对匹配的。这是她穿戴的东西。只有她、帮她穿衣的女人，也许还有她的情夫才能看到。口袋几乎就像内衣一样，尤其是那些漂亮昂贵的口袋。口袋是这种亲密的东西，贴近身体，将你最宝贵的物品
safe under the layers of your ginormous fluffy dress. And then came the French Revolution. The French Revolution happened. Which in many ways was a revolution against excess. These dresses that were made with voluminous silk skirts were no longer fashionable and what was fashionable were muslin dresses that clung to the body. So when you get to the 1800 and that empire style where the waist is pretty much gone, you know,
安全地藏在巨大蓬松的裙子层层叠叠之下。然后法国大革命爆发了。法国大革命发生了。这在许多方面是一场反对过度奢华的革命。那些用庞大丝绸裙摆制作的连衣裙不再流行，流行的是紧贴身体的平纹细布连衣裙。所以当你进入1800年代和那个高腰线风格基本消失的帝国风时，你知道的，
think of Jane Austen movies. You have the Kalomner silhouette. A silhouette like a straight Greek column. And some of these Kalomner dresses have slits for pockets, but a lot of them are too bodyhugging to accommodate extra bulge. There's no space for pockets, and so suddenly women begin to carry little purses. And there's lots of ridicule about women having to lose
想想简·奥斯汀的电影。你拥有柱状轮廓。像直立的古希腊圆柱一样的轮廓。其中一些柱状连衣裙有供口袋用的狭缝，但很多款式过于贴身，容纳不下额外的鼓包。没有放口袋的空间，于是女性突然开始携带小钱包。并且有很多关于女性不得不失去
their pockets and having to carry these silly bags. And at the time they called them reticules because they were so small. It's like ridiculous. Like ridiculous. Reticules were teeny, teeny tiny little drawstring pouches, elaborately beaded and decorated. They held maybe a few coins and some keys, but like that's it. And you could hang the loops of the drawstring around your wrist, which was another reason why
口袋而不得不携带这些愚蠢包包的嘲笑。当时他们把它们称为网袋（reticules），因为它们太小了。就像荒谬（ridiculous）一样。就像荒谬一样。网袋是极其微小的抽绳小袋，上面有精美的串珠和装饰。它们可能装着几枚硬币和一些钥匙，但也就仅此而已了。你可以把抽绳的环挂在手腕上，这也是为什么
it was considered ridiculous. You have to remember to carry it. It's easy to lose. People can steal it. That's the formal difference. But that's kind of the price you pay for a fashion. The little bags were in style. And I mean, you can see why, if you look at them,
它被认为是荒谬的。你必须记得随身携带它。它很容易丢。别人可以偷走它。这就是形式上的区别。但这算是你为时尚付出的代价。这种小包当时很流行。而且我的意思是，如果你看一下它们，你就能理解为什么，
they're beautiful. They're very fancy, beautiful things, shell shaped, or made of silk and gorgeous things. They're to be seen, they're not particularly capacious. This is dress historian Barbara Burman. The reticule becomes a kind of temporary fashionista thing, and so you get journalist writing in the first and second decades of the 19th century about
它们很漂亮。它们是非常别致、漂亮的东西，贝壳形状的，或者由丝绸和华丽的东西制成。它们是用来炫耀的，并不是特别能装。这是服装历史学家芭芭拉·伯曼。网袋变成了一种暂时的时尚潮流，所以在19世纪的第一个和第二个十年里，你会看到记者撰写关于
pocketists and anti-poketists. The fashion press made pockets seem like they were for housewives, for women who needed to lug around sewing kits and bits of food they were saving for later. Anti-poketists were going out dancing and gambling. They have these beautiful little reticles and they are much more fashionable and they don't need to carry keys and bibles and stacks of pins or all these useful things in their pockets because they don't do, they don't have that kind of life. They're much more out and about.
“口袋主义者”和“反口袋主义者”的文章。时尚界让口袋看起来像是家庭主妇穿的，是那些需要拖着缝纫包和留着以后吃的食物碎片的女性用的。反口袋主义者则外出跳舞和赌博。她们拿着这些漂亮的小网袋，时尚得多，她们不需要在口袋里装钥匙、圣经、一叠别针或所有这些有用的东西，因为她们不那样做，她们不过那种生活。她们更多地在外活动。
And so you have the pocketist, anti-pocketist debate that's strong along to gain readership I suppose. In the 19th century, fashion magazines were saying it was a liberating thing for women not to have pockets, to be free from tasks, reticules which hardly held anything, were kind of like long nails that don't let you use your hands as much, or siletto heels that don't let you walk as far. There's that luxury in not moving too much or doing too much and just looking really good.
所以你就有了“口袋主义者”和“反口袋主义者”的辩论，我想这在当时是为了吸引读者而大肆宣扬的。在19世纪，时尚杂志声称对女性来说没有口袋是一种解放，是从繁杂事务中解脱出来。几乎装不下东西的网袋，就像长指甲一样，让你没法充分使用双手，或者像细高跟鞋一样，让你无法走太远的路。不走太多路、不做太多事、只是看起来非常漂亮，本身就是一种奢侈。
And it's always been an ongoing debate if that is empowering or not. But it's not like the reticule completely killed the tie-on pocket. They were still around. A woman could perfectly well have a pair of pockets and also a reticule for when she wanted to be at show. They coexist and this kind of pocket clearly outlives the reticule. You find them in use in the 17th century, going right through to the 20th century.
这是否赋予女性权力，一直是一场正在进行的辩论。但网袋并没有完全杀死系带口袋。它们依然存在。一个女人完全可以拥有一对口袋，同时也备有一个网袋，以便在想要显摆时使用。它们共存着，这种口袋显然比网袋更长寿。你发现它们从17世纪一直使用到20世纪。
So why don't we have these anymore, if it wasn't for the club? It's such a waste of life. So it's me. You know, if you can come up with a good answer, it's very difficult to pinpoint it. They fade from use, they become old fashioned. More dresses start to have integrated pockets,
那么，如果不是因为俱乐部的原因，我们为什么不再拥有这些了呢？这真是对生命的巨大浪费。所以是我。你知道的，如果你能给出一个好答案的话。这很难精确指出。它们逐渐淡出人们的视野，变得过时。更多的连衣裙开始拥有内置口袋，
but they're often very small. They're not always, but they're often very small, not always, but they are often very small and very difficult to access. The women's wear that had integrated pockets tended to be feminized versions of men's wear. Made by men, they're made by tailors, not dress makers, and out of habits, tailors would be putting in proper fitted-in pockets, so to speak, like men's pockets, so they're because they're using male tailoring techniques. Basically, if an outfit had an in-set pocket,
但它们通常非常小。它们并非总是如此，但通常非常小，并非总是如此，但它们通常非常小且极难够到。带有内置口袋的女装往往是男装的女性化版本。由男性制作，由裁缝而非女装裁缝制作，出于习惯，裁缝会制作出适当合身的口袋，可以说是像男式口袋那样，因为他们使用的是男装剪裁技术。基本上，如果一套服装有嵌入式口袋，
it was a uselessly proportioned version of a man's pattern. The pocket is seen to be a monopoly of the male sex, eventually. It's pockets and trousers are one. And as women's fashions change, pockets can be lost. And as men's fashions change, pockets can be lost. And as men's fashions change, pockets can be gained. And they were, again and again and again, pockets were getting added and added and added over the course of decades. And by the early 20th century, it was just getting ridiculous.
那就是男士纸样的一个比例毫无用处的版本。最终，口袋被视为男性的专属领地。口袋和裤子是一体的。随着女装时尚的改变，口袋可能会消失。随着男装时尚的改变，口袋可能会增加。并且它们不断地、不断地、不断地在数十年的进程中被添加口袋。到了20世纪初，这简直变得荒谬可笑。
Copious amounts of pockets. I can't even like you have your ticket pocket for the train, you have your coin pocket, watch pocket, breast pocket. Then you have all the pockets in your waistcoat and then in your trousers. It's really interesting and women have one purse. Both gendered extremes were starting to get terrible. Because pockets had proliferated, they had become completely worthless. You couldn't find anything. You've stopped on the street, you have to pat yourself down to remember where you've left your wallet. The average man of 1944 had 24 pockets.
数量惊人的口袋。我甚至无法向你说明——你有放火车票的口袋，你有零钱袋、表袋、胸袋。然后你背心和裤子里还有所有的口袋。这真的很有趣，而女性只有一个钱包。这两种性别极端都开始变得糟糕。由于口袋泛滥，它们变得完全一无是处。你走在街上停下来，必须拍打自己全身来回想把钱包落在哪里了。1944年的普通男性有24个口袋。
Way too many. At least according to Bernard Rudolfski. He was kind of enraged by the way that pockets kept sort of popping up. Bernard Rudolfski was an architect, a modernist architect, and modernists were really into sleek, simple buildings that were absolutely functional with no excess. He was this modernist who wanted to make clothing perfectly rational. And he found it ironic that all his fellow rational modernist architects were all wearing suits. He wanted to, I think, shake up this confidence that we have about the suit and suggest, no, no, it is not modern in any way.
太多了。至少根据伯纳德·鲁道夫斯基的说法是这样的。他对口袋不断涌现的方式感到愤怒。伯纳德·鲁道夫斯基是一位建筑师，一位现代主义建筑师，现代主义者非常喜欢线条流畅、简单、绝对实用且没有多余装饰的建筑。他是那种想要让服装变得完全理性的现代主义者。他发现讽刺的是，他所有理性的现代主义建筑师同行们居然都在穿西装。我想，他希望打破我们对西装的这种迷信，并指出：不，不，它一点也不现代。
It has all sorts of old ideas and beliefs, and this pocket that was once functional is now no longer functional because we have so many. And to prove his point, Godloven, Rudolfski puts on an exhibit at the New York Museum of Modern Art in 1944, and it was called our Close Modern question mark. Our Close Modern was the question. The answer was no.
它包含着各种陈旧的思想和信仰，而这个曾经实用的口袋现在已经不再实用，因为我们有太多口袋了。为了证明他的观点，戈德洛文·鲁道夫斯基在1944年的纽约现代艺术博物馆举办了一个展览，名为“我们的服装现代吗？”。我们的服装现代吗是这个问题。答案是否定的。
The central piece in Rudolfski's Moma exhibit was this big, multi-layered infographic chart. It looked like an X-ray of a man's three-piece suit. We have color-coded the pockets in his shirt, in his vest, in his coat, and overcoat. And you see this wonderful, sort of chaotic overlay of 24 pockets. The average suit had 24 pockets and 70 buttons. Rudolfski was really passionate about how completely silly and redundant this was.
鲁道夫斯基在现代艺术博物馆展览的核心展品是一张大型的、多层的图表。它看起来像是一套男士三件套西装的X光片。我们用颜色标出了他衬衫、马甲、上衣和外套里的口袋。你可以看到这幅奇妙的、某种程度上混乱重叠的24个口袋图。普通西装有24个口袋和70颗纽扣。鲁道夫斯基对这完全是愚蠢和多余的做法感到非常激昂。
The guy is a wonderful nutball. But Rudolfski was really onto something, because he wasn't only about abolishing suits. He thought that at the root of this insane pocket conundrum was a much larger problem, which is about generally what we consider clothing to be. Clothing hanging on hangars to him looked like people's sort of dead skins. You know, and he wanted to be able to show that we, you know, you could travel to a friend's house and they would have clothes for you because clothing wouldn't be individual to the body. A universal size, universal clothing, unisex clothing.
这家伙是个绝妙的怪人。但鲁道夫斯基确实抓住了重点，因为他不仅致力于废除西装。他认为这场疯狂口袋迷局的根源是一个更大、更普遍的问题，即我们通常认为服装是什么。对悬挂在衣架上的服装来说，在他看来，它们就像人们某种死去的皮肤。你知道的，他希望能够表明，我们，你知道的，你可以去朋友家旅行，他们会为你准备衣服，因为衣服不会是个体身体专属的。一种普遍的尺寸，通用的服装，中性服装。
Universal clothing, according to Rudolfski, would be more like a toga or a peril that embraced the nature of cloth itself, something that would drape and move naturally. You know, he hated the idea that through clothes we could show ideas about status and gender that were unfair. He hated the expense, the waste, and so he wanted this, you know, really simple cloth. And of course, the images that he showed, his ideas for this new utopian future, are very
根据鲁道夫斯基的说法，通用服装应该更像是一件托加长袍或拥抱布料本身天然特性的服饰，一种会自然垂坠和活动的服装。你知道，他讨厌那种通过服装展示不公平的地位和性别观念的想法。他讨厌昂贵的费用和浪费，所以他想要这种真正简单的布料。当然，他展示的图片、他为这个乌托邦式新未来提出的构想，是非常
simple clothing that have no pockets. A world with no pockets at all and no bags. You might know the perfect world when you arrive there by its pocketlessness. My college friend Pierce got really into researching and reading about pockets long after his debacle with my dress. There's this whole strain of thought which suggests that if the world were perfect, if society were perfect, if we lived in a utopia of some kind, where you didn't have to worry about your physical safety,
没有口袋的简单服装。一个完全没有口袋、也没有包的世界。当你到达那个完美的无口袋世界时，你就会认出它来。我大学时的朋友皮尔斯在经历了我裙子的惨剧很久之后，开始狂热地研究和阅读有关口袋的书籍。有一种全方位的思想流派表明，如果世界是完美的，如果社会是完美的，如果我们生活在某种乌托邦中，在那里你不必担心自己的人身安全，
you didn't have to worry about somebody robbing your house, you wouldn't need pockets in order to carry money in order to carry keys. And certainly, in the course of time, we have come to hold fewer and fewer things in our pockets. All those little devices that Jeffersz or contained in a single phone that we carry externally on our body, and the pocket really is this sort of knowledge envelope, this compartment. But the phone stays adjacent to us, removed, encased in a bag or pocket. And tech companies have tried to sell us on wearables, on Apple Watches and Google Glasses,
你不必担心有人抢劫你的家，你就不需要为了携带金钱、携带钥匙而准备口袋。当然，在时间的推移中，我们口袋里装着的东西越来越少。杰斐逊随身携带的所有那些小装置都被包含在一个我们随身携带并置于体外的手机中，而口袋实际上就是这样一个知识信封、这样一个隔间。但手机仍然与我们相邻，被移除并包在包或口袋里。科技公司一直试图向我们推销可穿戴设备，比如苹果手表和谷歌眼镜，
which would take your tools out of your pocket entirely, and maybe bring us a step closer to that pocketless utopia. But these products haven't taken off in the way they were supposed to. Wearables were foreseen a long time ago, and we still feel a little bit anxious about their use. I think there's just too much doubt at the moment about whether that utopia can ever work. And perhaps one day we will have all of our tools implanted in our skull or embedded on an accessory which everyone will be able to access in the same way. And then when we get there, pockets will
这些设备将彻底把你的工具从你的口袋里解放出来，也许能让我们离那个没有口袋的乌托邦更近一步。但这些产品并没有像预期那样流行起来。可穿戴设备很早就被预见了，但我们对它们的使用仍然感到有些焦虑。我认为目前对于这种乌托邦是否真的行得通，还存在太多的疑虑。也许有一天，我们的所有工具都会植入我们的头骨中，或者嵌入每个人都能以同样方式访问的配件中。然后，当我们到达那一步时，口袋将
seem just as ancient as Rudolfsky thought them to be. Already it seems so antiquated that clothes are needlessly gendered in the way they are. Because we should all have access to the tools we need. Or at least a place to put our hands. The piece of paper Words from yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things we love Articles of interest is made by myself, Averchrupplement No. Articles of interest is made by myself, Aver Troubleman, with editing from Katie Mingle and Joe Rosenberg, music by Ray Royal, intro and outro themes
显得和鲁道夫斯基想象的那样古老。服装以这种方式进行不必要的性别划分，这在今天看来已经如此陈旧。因为我们都应该能够获得我们需要的工具。或者至少有一个放手的地方。昔日的片纸字句。在我们所爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。服装趣谈由我制作，Averchrupplement。不。服装趣谈由我自己Aver Troubleman制作，凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）参与编辑，雷·罗伊（Ray Royal）配乐，片头和片尾主题曲
by Susami Ashworth, fact check by Graham Hisha, mixed by Sheree Fusef, and Roman Mars is the deep pockets of this whole series. Special thanks to Peer's Gellie for telling me about this topic in his podcast, Celerdore, as well as to Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Kurt Colstad, Sean Riel, and the whole 99PI team. The fakes on women's wear are proof that fashion always takes useful things and makes them ridiculous. Fashionable dress prefers the assertion of utility to utility itself.
由苏萨米·阿什沃思（Susami Ashworth）创作，格雷厄姆·希沙（Graham Hisha）进行事实核查，谢里·福塞夫（Sheree Fusef）混音，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是整个系列的幕后推手。特别感谢皮尔斯·格利（Peer's Gellie）在他的播客Celerdore上向我讲述这个话题，同时也感谢德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·李（Vivian Lee）、库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）、肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）以及整个99PI团队。女装上的假口袋证明了时尚总是将有用的东西变得荒谬可笑。时尚的服装更倾向于标榜实用性，而非实用性本身。
Like how plaid fell into style once it couldn't be worn in Scotland anymore, or how high heels developed from riding shoes, but became trendy once we took them off horseback. Who was it? Oh, Anne Hollander notes that fashion instantly mocks sensible inventions and clothing, subjecting them to unfunctional usage as soon as they appear.
就像格子呢一旦不能在苏格兰穿之后是如何流行起来的，或者高跟鞋是如何从骑马鞋发展而来，但在我们把它们从马背上脱下后却变得时髦一样。是谁说的来着？哦，安·霍兰德指出，时尚会立即嘲笑服装中的明智发明，一旦它们出现，就会迫使其用于非功能性的用途。
And that's absolutely true of pockets. I mean, you can think of the wonderful ornate suits of the macaroni. Like when Yankee Doodle sticks a feather in his hat, he thinks that makes him one of these dandy macaroni. Who were these British youth in the 1770s and 80s? These young men with big elaborate hairdos and these tight little coats coats and their coats were so narrow and form fitting that once again in the name of fashion their front pockets became useless. And so now they have this pocket that makes no sense and so tailors invented what is the breast pocket, put it you know inside the coat at the breast.
对于口袋来说绝对是这样。我的意思是，你可以想到花花公子华丽的华达呢（macaroni）西装。就像当扬基·都德在帽子上插上一根羽毛时，他认为这让他成了这些花花公子（macaroni）之一。1770年代和80年代的这些英国年轻人是谁？这些年轻男人有着精致庞大的发型和这些紧绷的小外套，他们的外套如此狭窄和修身，以至于为了时尚的名义，他们的前口袋再次变得无用了。所以现在他们有了这个毫无意义的口袋，于是裁缝们发明了所谓的胸袋，把它放在外套胸部的内部。
Clothing is always shifting in and out of practicality and sometimes just because something is useless doesn't mean it's meaningless. Like with a pocket, even if it can't hold much, sometimes it matters that it's there. And sometimes, it matters exactly how it's placed. Your next article of interest is The Hawaiian Shirt. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
服装总是在实用与不实用之间摇摆不定，有时仅仅因为某物无用并不意味着它毫无意义。就像口袋一样，即使它装不了多少东西，有时它存在本身就很重要。有时，它放置的具体位置也很重要。你的下一个服装趣谈是：夏威夷衫。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。